as the january 6th hearings highlight
our nation's political divisions several
former military leaders including
retired army general stanley mcchrystal
and army general doug lute are urging
americans to recommit to this country's
core principles they are part of a group
called team democracy that wants people
to pledge that elections are conducted
according to the rule of law without
partisan bias the general spoke with
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herrich about the new
initiative and why they believe our
democracy faces its greatest threat
since the civil war
i actually think that this is as
dangerous a time as we've seen in our
lifetime retired army general stanley
mcchrystal who once led u.s forces
around the globe including afghanistan
sees america's current divisions as an
issue of national security because you
see the symptoms of people who are
disassociated from the legitimacy of the
government they are starting to question
basic things like was an election
outcome valid i'm beginning to see as
stan suggested these fissures retired
lieutenant general doug lute also served
globally over a four decade career
including as u.s ambassador to nato
these tiny fractures these small
fractures that because of our
international experience we understand
can widen and can be and can divide
america it can actually present
opportunities for our opponents it's not
every day that you have two retired
generals sit down and talk about the
state of our elections why are you
coming forward
our enemies would like nothing more than
to find us
not unified to find us fragmented and
unable to be the kind of america that
they have faced before or relied on it
their allies i think stan and i have
seen democracies fledgling democracies
overseas struggle to find their feet and
at least for me i see some of those
warning signs today in america
as seasoned observers of conflict these
generals joined team democracy to
highlight core principles the idea is to
give every american a reminder
and a commitment that safe and fair
elections are fundamental to our nation
and democracy the election was rigged it
was stolen without the backing of former
president trump and his supporters how
can this work well it starts with the
grassroots movement every american has
got to step back and say what do i
really believe in about our nation and
that is that we are a democracy what
signals that the fact that i believe and
participate in the elections the thing
that unites us is that before we were
supporters of president trump or
president biden or obama we were
americans we are americans
fearful of america's military
superiority these generals say our
adversaries use information as a weapon
to mislead confuse and divide if i were
an adversary of the united states i want
to go after two things first would be
our political unity our ability to make
unified decisions and execute things but
i'd also want to go after our legitimacy
as a nation that other nations want to
emulate from an intelligence perspective
why are americans so divided when people
get messages that are very direct and
often they are either intentionally or
unintentionally incorrect it changes
their beliefs and so they start to hold
fundamental ideas that are contrary to
facts it actually opens opportunities
for those who do us harm and eventually
their aim is to make us so divided that
we're internally consumed we're
self-absorbed with our own problems and
we're unable to address issues overseas
recent cbs news polling underscores the
divisions with most americans expecting
violence after future presidential
elections this is not the america that
we've come to expect of ourselves i
think if we look in cases where people
think violence is an option or even an
obligation then we are starting to have
drifted somewhere that we see in other
countries far away but it's suddenly
come home and we need to pay close
attention to it and once that drift
begins it's very difficult to reverse it
so now is the time as a preventive
measure we need to get in front of these
divides
and try to cement ourselves back
together
the generals have not announced a
complete plan of action yet but believe
asking people from across the political
spectrum to recommit to core democratic
principles is a good starting point and
the group cites research that public
pledges can drive behavior especially
when paired with public accountability
efforts michelle the nation is at stake
catherine thank you